hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on monster hundred
world again and today we have one of
three videos that I plan on releasing
one today one a little bit later and
that one probably tomorrow morning of
the newest guides that I've just fully
completed
we have Naga Kouga than we have Glavine
us who if you've gotten an Argo Kouga or
if you beaten you know there during the
same quest and then the third one after
I won't spoil just in case you don't
know who it is but it's completely
understandable yeah we're gonna be going
over Naga Kouga today veterans of
Monster Hunter will remember her from
the past games but newer hunters just
like myself will see this as a new
formidable challenge so this is this was
a really fun fight to do as long as like
the V if you do enjoy subscriber for new
now let's get started for Narga Kouga
her weakness is fire and thunder thunder
is a three star and fire is the two star
she's resistant to water and can inflict
bleed with the tail all ailments by the
way are also two stars so if you have
some type of combo for example I know
one of the dual blades is poison and
fire you can get the two fire you can
get the two stars from the fire and then
the two stars and the poison if you're
down to do that but I just stuffed with
a thunder weapon could seem to be the
most popular for me she also has an
enraged state which is pretty obvious to
tell from her red eyes because if she's
not she'll just have her normal pupils
be black so it's very obvious to tell
when she's in an enraged state or not in
the story you fight her in the ancient
forest and then after that you fight
Glavine is depending on which already
you fought them and you may have fought
him first you may be fighting him last I
fought in our kakuka first that's why
this guide is coming first for some
small tips I do recommend atemporal
Rocksteady or vitality for the mantle
either option is cool I usually bring
the temporal anyway on the first flight
just so I can kind of get a handle for
what the monsters doing but if you want
to spice it up a bit grab different
Mantle's if you want to grab it in
affinity booster a health booster
everything is completely fine all
options are available for this one
surprisingly I didn't really find Naga
Cougar that hard to fight I'm not sure
if Naga cuca was like that and the past
games but at least from my experience I
happen to down her in about 25 to 30
minutes which isn't great but for it
being the first time I fought her ever
so I think that's pretty good for me and
without I think I went down maybe one
time so I think I did pretty well I
thought that she would be a little bit
harder but maybe I just got lucky
sometimes naga cougar really likes to
use her tail sometimes uses it a bit too
much and can get it stuck in the ground
you can use this opportunity to use the
clutch claw and possibly sever the tail
or smack or weak points whatever you
want to do whatever you're in the mood
for only thing about the tail being gone
though is that if you get rid of it you
can't throw the spikes anymore which can
inflict bleed so you definitely have to
watch out for that but it keeps her from
getting stuck on the ground which is the
kind of a hindrance but at the end of
the day it's really not that big of a
deal so I usually just keep the tail and
I usually just sever it once I need a
tail for some type of armor or weapon in
the future I might just do that
honestly though her her move set is
pretty small and her moves are also
fairly dodge able as well very easy such
as the - forward bite in the tail swipe
tail swipe obviously you want to be
underneath her or you want to be far
enough away so that it doesn't hit you
and for the dashboard just off to the
sides that really shouldn't be that big
of a deal if you do happen to get caught
though if you have the temporal you'll
be fine rock steady would go right
through it vitality will eat the damage
and depending on your defense and other
type of resistances you should be fine
as well but because you're in the
ancient forest I actually find that it's
more in your favor because you can
utilize the loads of breakables and vine
traps throughout the map to easily
Whittle her down her health right in the
beginning area where you normally fight
her at least where I fought her there
was a vine trap and as you can tell I
went to go for the mount to get a little
bit extra damage but she accidentally
walked into the vine trap tripping it
which ended up actually wasting my mount
but it wasn't that big of a deal because
there was three other vine traps I
happen to use and then there was the big
boulder that's breakable inside of the
tree that you can use but I haven't been
able to fight her down there maybe she
didn't move there in my game maybe she
will move there for years but if she
does there's always that giant boulder
you can slam right down in her skull she
also likes to do this swing around move
like tigress and berry I like to do in
Chi swing so definitely watch out for
that second hit just in case you dodged
the first and if she hits you with their
tail just pop a smoke bomb or hit or
hide and crouch you get rid of that
bleeding if you have the sutra skill
which you'll eventually get at level 4
throughout the story I'm unaware if this
is the cholesterol order you get for
completing the next this quest with
these two monsters or if it's before or
after but you do get one of those which
can definitely help with the bleeding on
that one bhasu though that's really it
like I said gnar kakuka really doesn't
have a crazy large move set and her
moves are fairly easily dodged able so
it really shouldn't be that big of an
issue one of the one move that of course
will hinder you a bit is the bleed but
if you have that suture skill honestly
you've basically negated all of the
stuff that she has a potential for when
our Kouga is enraged though she does
become faster and more deadly but it
does proxy agitate
skill so if you do have that it will
come in handy even more honestly even
when she was enraged I wasn't feeling
like I needed to hold back until one
Mantle's already or poppity other
necessary other elements or anything
like that so honestly she seemed very
similar when she was enraged and I had
no problem beating her as always if you
guys have any questions leave them down
in the comments below and if I happen to
miss something or get something wrong
and I'll make a whole list of all the
stuff that you guys have told me in a
pin comment down below if there's enough
details and then so that everything
everybody can be kept updated with all
that info because obviously I'm just one
guy I don't know every single bit of
detail so other people and other
different experiences can really help
with that as well yeah guys like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe for free new I
covered the solo guides of monster
hunter world so if you want to be kept
up to date with all that stuff and want
to make sure that you know how to defeat
the monsters whether it's for your first
time in the story mode or if you want to
get a little bit of a refresher learn
how to farm the character stuff like
that get the extra bit of armor and
weapons I totally understand that guys
think for watching the video hope you
guys did enjoy like I said take care
have a great astir day and enjoy the
rest of the ice-born story
[Music]
you
[Music]